[Music]
you
hello and welcome to this video this is
our chapter on the Dutch defense they
are the Dutch defense
happens after d4 f5 f5 is a very
ambitious move by black and some yeah
oftentimes played by players who want a
non symmetrical position right away and
this is definitely what they get
however f5 also has some drawbacks it is
a weakening move for the kingside is
severely weakened and this is also why
the - defense is sometimes viewed as a
little bit suspicious by many strong
players or are theoreticians still it's
very important to be equipped with some
ideas because as mentioned it is
ambitious and usually complicated now
what to do against the - um the Dutch
defense basically has one main line
approach that white can try against or
white can play some gamma of beat lines
on the second move some of those are
actually quite interesting for example I
have played the move Knight c3 here one
there is Bishop to g5 those moves are
all very well respected lines there is
however a move order issue the Dutch
most of the time arises why I defy f5
but that is not a given um some like
players are cunning with their move
water they start with another different
first move and only then transposed to
the Dutch that can happen for example
after D 46 after which we go an idea 3
according to our repertoire concept and
then they could play a 5 and then you
Knight c3 ideas a little bit out of the
picture at least they don't make that
much sense anymore the same goes for
meeeeee move orders like this d 693 g6
g3 we are expecting a king's indian to
happen and then all of a sudden they
play a 5 or they let us win another move
and then they play a 5 so there are
actually many ways you can even look at
like this eunuch 9 f3 e6 g3 f5 and all
of a sudden it is a Dutch I know those
move waters are not as frequently seen
as d4 f5
people want to go for the Dutch but it's
possible and the problem is if you learn
some specific line to this move order
like this for example as mentioned it's
not all you need to know you also need
to be aware that they can do stuff like
this and then you are in a king size
fianchetto set up against the Dutch so
as mentioned the King side fianchetto is
the absolute main line against the Dutch
anyway so the most frequently played
move and the move usually recommended by
a theoreticians is to move g3 in this
position or Knight f3 and then g3 and
this is our general repertoire approach
anyway so I decided to simply cover the
main lines against the Dutch and stick
to our usual King side fee and Cairo set
up the reasoning why g3 Bishop g2 a king
size in Cairo is a good setup against
the Dutch is that the bishop on g2 is if
we put up some more moves like this for
example the bishop on g2 is having some
currently indirect influence over the e4
square and white as a general plan wants
to play E for at some point open up the
central position and often expose
weaknesses that black has created its
will not yeah black will not just play
e6 or g6 but play other pawn moves and
usually on the e-file there's something
that we can play for so II for is a
standard break that white wants to apply
in the Dutch um in the Dutch defence
black has three main setups that we will
cover and some oddities I will start
with the oddities but later we will also
look at the classical Dutch the
classical Dutch is a combination of the
moves ecigs and d6 like c-46 would be
the classical Dutch
um black awesome place the so-called
Stonewall with d5 setting up this pawn
Center he adds um yeah yeah II five the
weak squares main theme we will go um I
will talk about the main ideas when we
look about look at the specific
variations and the third main line is g6
the leningrad touch which is probably
nowadays the most frequently seen line
and also the one with with the best
theoretical reputation now and we need
to look at some outlines though um we
will go with Knight f3 on the second you
can also go g3 it doesn't really make a
huge difference in some cases after to
g3 there are options to later use the
knight on a different square than f3 but
this is not very relevant for us because
we will have many move orders like as
mentioned this where we have committed
the night anyway to f3 so let's have a
look at some of the odd lines we go
Knight f3 and now black in the absolute
majority of times plays Knight to f6 and
then decides on a pond setup in the
center it can also play a pawn move now
like d66 g6 one of those and they are
usually transpositional um we will talk
about g6 a little bit later when we look
at the leningrad formation because this
is a clear relative to that but i can
also go d 6e m and then later and
suppose again to a leningrad or your
classical dutch with ecigs and d6 is all
very flexibly move order but we do the
same we play the same moves every time
um hmm you can also play east six and
now decide on set up for example he
could go b 6 and can we reach something
like that that we will examine actually
in a minute why am the more common move
autumn of night f6
this is the best square for them night
anyway it makes a lot of sense to
control reform so we call g3 and now the
big parting of the ways here g6 is the
leningrad a6 is the classical or
stonewall most of the time and black has
some really rare lines available let's
have a look at 1 d6 Bishop g2 and now
the very uncommon move c6 it's um an
offbeat idea like a black wants to play
Queen c7 and e5 alright so we cancel as
usual like goes Queen to c7 trying to
prepare e5 the drawback is that this is
a very slow approach and black moves the
Queen I'm very early on yeah I recommend
to play a little bit differently than we
usually do see 45 is not bad for white
but it makes sense him to go for very
quickly form just play the Knight to c3
and prepare a form quickly um a real
attractive point about this move is that
blacks um planned move he wants to go if
v clearly it is actually not good YUM
we will have a look at this in a second
um black probably should not go a 5 but
rather play a move like g6 after which I
recommend to play rook e1 and prepare a
form now this is excellent for one yeah
we see that we are much better develop
and will open up the center with e4
quickly and d5 is extremely ugly giving
us yeah more Tempe even it looks we
offer so rook e1 is a good move I need
to mention that I had this on the board
once actually a long time ago and I
played the extremely aggressive move Eve
form because I mean I felt that I should
have to punish this what black is doing
um but if I it's not as as good as rook
e1 it's possible it's not a terrible
move but it's a bit over aggressive and
rook e1 is just strong now if black cozy
5 which is the most likely case given
that here
start with that we can capture only five
and now play the movie form this is a
very typical counterpunch in the dutch
defense whenever black tries to set up
this pawn to e5 and f5 and we will see
this idea later in the classical dutch
and in the leningrad we want to be ready
to either prevent us completely or if we
have to allow it then we want to be
absolutely ready to fight it with an e
for a counter punch preventing black
from advancing the pawn even further
here a black isn't actually quite
terrible shape um if he now tries to
support the center with Bishop to d6 we
have a very strong move available I'm
sorry this is not the only one but this
is very strong Bishop h3 it's a bit
uncommon but it's very strong in a
tactical way we attack at five and black
probably has to capture it and really
see what else you can do um and then we
can take on c8 initiating an interesting
technical sequence now the Queen has to
cover this so black will have to take
him and now we have Bishop takes b7 and
black is already busted basically has to
take in d6 and blacks position is
already falling apart you know that he
has
[Music]